service accounts where do they come from
in the last episode i mentioned that
there are some service accounts that are
created automatically for us
like google managed service accounts and
default service accounts
that's really nice but you might want to
know how to create your own
after that how will you manage them what
will you do when you need to get rid of
one
these questions mean that it's time to
talk about what's what with creating
managing and retiring your service
accounts creating a service account is
as easy as one g
cloud command g cloud i am service
accounts create
upon creation this new service account
will have no rules assigned so
zero access to any apis and services
before we talk about assigning roles and
permissions let's iron out the creation
process a little bit more
every service account should have a
purpose one of the best best practices
that you could
practice is to make sure a service
account's purpose is clear to you
and to any other administrator that
might inherit your project in the future
so when you create a service account
make sure that you include a descriptive
display name
if you want to take it a step further
and i recommend that you do
you can include even more details and
context in the service accounts
description
when creating service accounts make it a
habit to figure out a meaningful display
name and description
on creation by tagging on the display
name and description flags to your
gcloud command
this will be especially useful if your
project accumulates a long list of
service accounts
each with a different purpose and set of
iam roles assigned to it
you can view the display name and
description for any service account
using
gcloud i am service accounts described
followed by the service account email
you can always update these fields in
the console or by using the cli
with gcloud im service accounts update
when you have service accounts in your
project a big part of managing them is
managing the iam roles and permissions
associated with them
if you're already familiar with google
cloud's iam policies then you might
already know that checking what a
service account is capable of doing is
as simple as checking the iam policy of
your project
gcloud projects get i am policy followed
by your project id will show you all the
iam role bindings
on your project including the rules
assigned to your service accounts
service account management doesn't only
mean understanding what resources
service accounts have access to
but also who has access to your service
accounts
when you're taking a look at your iam
policy take note of any accounts that
have roles associated with managing or
using service accounts
this includes pre-defined roles like
service account token creator
service account admin and service
account key admin
some of these roles will allow users to
make changes to or even
act as service accounts that means it's
technically possible for a user that you
intend to be restricted to have
unrestricted permissions
via a service account with bloated
access
it's a security topic that we'll cover
in a later episode
in addition to the iam policy on your
project there is also an iam policy for
each service account in your project
the role bindings on these policies are
limited specifically to their
corresponding service account and are
not visible on the project's im policy
you can retrieve a particular service
accounts iim policy with gcloud
i am service accounts get in policy
followed by the account
email all of this role and policy info
is available from the cloud console
under iam and admin settings
there may come a day when you'll want to
get rid of the service account
you could just delete it but beware once
you do any users
applications or vms that are configured
to use it to access any resources will
lose that access
it is important to use caution when
deleting a service account
especially if you're not so sure about
what it's used for
it's much safer to disable it first
once an account is disabled yeah
applications will lose that access that
they had through it
just like when you delete it but a
disabled service account can easily be
re-enabled at any time
does that mean that when you delete a
service account it's completely totally
utterly and
hopelessly lost forever no not exactly
you could undelete a deleted service
account but
only if two things are true one
the service count had to have been
deleted within the past
30 days and two there can be no other
service accounts
in existence on your project the same
name as
the deleted service account that's
because disabling a service account will
reserve the name
but deleting it will not after you check
the service account's details and roles
and the site is probably not in use
you can disable the service account with
gcloud iam
service accounts disabled if it turns
out that the account is needed again for
whatever reason
enabling it is as simple as gcloud im
service accounts enabled
otherwise you can delete it with gcloud
im service accounts delete
so we talked about how we can best
create service accounts by providing
them with a clear purpose
and how to safely delete them by
disabling them first
we also talked about managing their
access by checking the project and
service account iam policies
that's only part of what goes into
managing service accounts
next time we'll expand on that and talk
a bit more about securing service
accounts
roles and in policies see you then